bonsoir jean paul chang merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous sur rt france ce soir
comment est-ce que vous analysez cette
dernière si tant est que ce soit la
dernière dernière tentative
agressifs en tout cas contre la chine du
coup tu avais annoncé récemment dans des
discours
je suis après les élections donc il a
dit quelque chose qui me lie à 100
breton attend qu'on finit avec la chine
a en tout cas et là on est une
illustration parce que c'est un
executive order du président portant sur
des problèmes de l'investissement dans
les entreprises chinoises et liste en
faible potentiel de 30 et une entreprise
chinoise qui sont accusés de damas
retenir l'armée ou de coopérer avec
l'armée
je pense que c'est une région très
symbolique c'est le cas c'est le cas et
pourquoi justement cibler ces
entreprises qui qui appartiendrait aux
militaires au fait est ce que c'est un
parti reuters sa copie avec l'éditeur
s'est pas tout à fait vrai puisque la
plupart des entreprises civiles même
indépendante travaille avec quelquefois
avec le secteur de la défense c'est vrai
dans tous les pays du monde
alors c'est plus un acte anti chinois
très symbolique parce que les
investissements américains dans les
entreprises chinoises cotées ou non
cotées représente très très peu saoulé
dans les temps les ressources
financières les entreprises chinoises
soient si l'entreprise
il y en a qui sont cotées sur le marché
de new york comme china telecom août à
nos mobiles qui sont effectivement des
compagnies téléphoniques
bon ils ont les indices américains en
principe jusqu'au mois de novembre
prochain
poucet de grâce et de leurs titres alors
on introduit ainsi une barrière
politique maintenant pour les
investisseurs ce qui est effectivement
nouveau même si jusqu'à maintenant on
prenait plutôt dans les pays occidentaux
et dans d'autres pays
des mesures pour empêcher que des
capitaux étrangers rang
dans les entreprises nationales pour des
raisons de sécurité de protection de
souveraineté etc etc
là c'est différent on veut empêcher
finalement les indices américains
d'acheter des titres chinois et de
gagner de l'argent là dessus est-ce que
ça va vraiment être mise en place
est-ce que d'ici le mois de novembre
l'année prochaine la prochaine est ce
que la nouvelle administration
américaine d'en faire quelque chose pour
revenir un peu en arrière ou continuer
cette politique en tout cas
l'administration trump a décidé de
laisser une sorte de terre boule et des
relations sino-américaines dans tous les
domaines et de continuer nous dans cette
positive de découplement économique et
financière la chine comment est-ce que
la chine voit l'arrivée de joe biden a
priori au pouvoir en janvier prochain la
chine qui a félicité aujourd'hui soit
dix jours après joe biden justement
comme président élu
je pense que les chiens parce que il
sera plus prévisible c'est à dire le
nouveau président à être plus
prédictibles dans les mesures
cela ne veut pas dire qu'ils mettent
beaucoup d'espoir sur une amélioration
rapide et profonde ou un abaissement
immédiat des relations sino américaines
mais au mois il doit il espère que les
choses se passent comme tu domines ya
moins brutal et moins soudaine et de
manière imprévisible et peut-être moins
extrémiste pour le moment la quiétude
des chinois ce n'est pas encore sûr
baden c'est les douze mois qui nous
séparent de l'investiture du nouveau
président et y pensent comment ils
redoutent un peu que des américains pas
une station l'histoire américaine
seulement sont exactes un peu
irréversible ou plus provocatrices et
dangereuses des actions dangereuses
notamment sur la question de taiwan si
les américains à sida nistration
américaine l'administration décide de
franchir quelques lignes rouges ligne
rouge aux jeunes et chinois sur les
questions de taiwan et bien les chinois
craignent que cinq crée finalement
d une situation difficile à manager pour
la prochaine administration sont très
courants quoi pourrait consister 7 cette
ligne rouge que pourrait franchir les
états unis à taïwan sur le plan
diplomatique ou sur le plan de l'éditeur
mec poupée ou a déclaré il ya moins de
48 heures il a dit que taiwan n'a jamais
fait partie de la chine
or il faut savoir que c'est quand même
sur la base de la reconnaissance d'une
de mendicité de la chine avec taiwan ap
l'appartenance de taïwan la chine que
les relations sino américaines ont été
établis en en 1960 79
donc si l'on revient là dessus qui est
un principe fondamental ça touche à
vraiment aux intérêts nationaux la chine
la situation risque de devenir plus
sérieuses entre la chine et les états
unis sur blanc diplomatique
merci beaucoup jean paul planque d'avoir
répondu ce soir en direct à vos
questions sur rt france